(intense music)
(quiet footsteps)
- [Interviewer] In an age of call outs,
culture wars, and perfect facades,
people can be afraid to
express how they really feel.
So we brought together seven strangers,
protected their identities,
and asked them all seven
burning audience questions.
What will be revealed
when we take the mask off?
(intense music)
- [Interviewer] If the answer is yes,
you will flip on your light.
(intense boom)
Do you watch porn?
(countdown beeping)
- It's accessible.
And because it's accessible,
accessible and it's there,
people use it.
I'm one of them.
- I think most guys can
agree that they have,
at least at some point, watched it.
And, you know, I mean it's,
if you can enjoy it in a healthy way,
if you can enjoy masturbating
in a healthy way,
I think then, like, by
all means, go for it.
- Yeah, I do watch porn.
God.
A lot of my teenage years,
I spent a lot of time
self-obsessing over it
to the point where it kind
of became an addiction.
And it took until very recently to get
out of the hole of, you
know, paying for porn.
I do watch it, but I don't
like that I watch it.
- [Interviewer] I'm
gonna bring everyone else
into the conversation.
- I said, no.
I used to watch it a lot before.
I would say I was addicted to it.
My dad is in prison.
So there was no one really
for me to talk to about sex.
So porn was my education on sex.
- From personal experience,
it messed me up because,
after watching it so much,
you know, I'm sure we've all been there,
where you're on page five
and like, nothing is right.
Like, you're looking for that right video.
But your dopamine receptors and everything
is so messed up at this point
that the same thing
that would get you off,
wouldn't get you off anymore, right?
I went so deep into it where me,
I'm a straight man,
I started watching trans porn
because it was just
erotic in a different way
that I've never seen before.
I needed more stimulation.
- Because of pornography?
- Yeah, because of pornography.
So I don't think it's just entertainment.
It actually affects with your brain
and the way you perceive love.
- You think that a lot of teenagers
or teen boys are really educated
on the effects of pornography?
- [All] No. (laughter)
(intense boom)
- [Interviewer] Have you ever cried
in front of someone else?
(countdown beeping)
- I wholeheartedly agree
with this statement.
I feel like it's easier
to open up towards women,
which is kind of embarrassing,
but, like, quite frankly
I feel like they understand
emotions more because they,
they really understand the whole crying.
I mean, I feel like crying
is sort of normal to them,
and they see of it as like
a way to express themselves.
- It's interesting that you said that
you're more comfortable
to cry in front of women.
I had a girlfriend and she
broke up with me over text.
And before that we were, like, talking,
and I cried in front of
her, and I was being honest,
and I thought that's what
you're supposed to do.
That's what my dad taught me, right?
But I guess she interpreted it
as being insecure, and
she broke up with me.
And that, that really messed
me up for a little while
because it's like, well now
I know I can't show any kind
of insecurity.
So I don't, I don't like
crying in front of women.
Like I'd rather cry in front
of some family that I trust.
Right?
- That's interesting because
I'd rather find a stranger
on the street and tell 'em
everything I'm going through,
- Me too.
- Because I will never
see them again in my life.
And I feel like they
won't be able to judge me.
- No strings attached.
- 'Cause I'll never see them.
- I'd rather have a
stranger think I'm strong.
And my family know all my
problems. So that's interesting.
(intense boom)
- [Interviewer] Feminism has gone too far.
(countdown beeping)
- In the feminism
movement, there's so much
of tearing down men or trying
to put men back in their spot,
but if the women want us men to step up,
then I feel like it'd be
a lot more productive,
instead of tearing down
men and telling us all
what we're doing wrong then to,
on the other hand to build us up.
I guess, for the sake of
keeping us accountable
for our actions, and as men
we also need to step up.
- Giving females more
opportunities to certain things,
I just think that's quite unfair,
and it's like, you gotta put in the work,
you gotta put in the certain thing,
certain things to earn these things.
And it's not like women
are granted less access
to these jobs.
I mean, I know there's plenty of women
who are in business, who are
doing good things for America.
I just find it counterintuitive that this
whole feminist movement is
advocating for equal rights
and certain things when they
already have access to them.
- I'm a feminist, I guess.
I believe in the equality
of men and women.
I think that when we talk about feminism,
a lot of it boils down to employment.
I think that the bringing down of men
you guys keep on saying, bringing
down men and shaming them.
I think that is way overstated.
I have never been shamed
for my, for my maleness.
- I think, you know, if
you look at any movement
there's definitely gonna
be like a radical portion
of that movement.
But at the same time, like
I wanna open up the question
to you guys.
Do any of you guys have
personal experience
where you feel you've been brought down,
you know like to bring a woman up?
- Uh, a little bit.
Little bit like in my, in high school.
And it's not like the worst
thing in the world that we have,
like in ASB my sophomore year,
there was like happy thoughts, right?
Like every Friday you
just write something,
and you put it in the bin.
It'll just be the girls,
and then some, you know,
more of the feminine guys
complimenting each other
which is not a problem,
but as they're complimenting each other,
"Oh look at you, you're killing it."
And then, and then they'll
even like insult me.
It went and went from being happy thought
to build up women day.
You know what I mean?
- I feel like there's a, there's a wall,
and we should break down that wall
and focus on the human rights.
Not women, not men,
not Mexicans, not this.
We should all bring each other up.
(intense boom)
- [Interviewer] I've been
anxious about my penis size.
(countdown beeping)
- I started watching pornography, I think,
around the age of 11 or 12.
And that's, you know, that's
a very impressionable,
vulnerable place to be in.
So, of course, there's
always these feelings
about looking at your body.
- Yeah, and I think the competition
is probably what affects me the most part,
you know, it's the the thing you're like,
I know good, well there's
dudes bigger than me.
And she says it doesn't matter,
but it still plays on
my mental when I wake,
when I go to sleep at night.
- Currently, I'm not really like afraid
of the size that I have
because I am kind of
becoming more confident
in my body and the way that I am.
And I don't really feel like
it's going to matter nearly as much
when you're with someone for 10 years,
as you are for like a one night stand.
So I am not personally like
that uncomfortable with my size.
- Everything that you just
said, like it is true.
And like, you just need
to become confident in,
in your own self by knowing
what people really look for.
But like, it's hard to get on Netflix
and watch Euphoria, and think like,
these are like grown-ass men
playing high school people.
And you think like, (beep) well,
that's not what I look like.
And then you think about like,
every person that I have been with,
or will be with, has probably seen this.
I think that's really where
that anxiety comes from is
it's just the fact that
other people probably have expectations.
(intense boom)
- [Interviewer] I have
questioned my sexuality.
(countdown beeping)
- I guess, growing up,
I was never one of like
the jocks of school.
I always was into music.
I was always into theater.
And so growing up, you
know, I was always bullied
because of that.
'Cause I was being too gay or whatever.
And I always hung out with the girls.
And so I definitely did kind of buy into
what everyone else was saying
in their peer pressure of
like saying, "Oh, you're gay.
This is how you're
gonna end up turning out
because this is how you are now."
With where I am now in my life,
I've just kind of gotten to a place
where I've grown to be confident.
I know what my identity is.
- People thinking that definitely, like,
it gets you thinking, you know,
it gets you thinking like,
well (beep), like, am I?
Or should I be? You know, it's like,
should I be attracted to
dudes because I like things
that are "gay", you know?
But then I guess it just reveals the issue
that like we've made certain things gay
and made certain things straight.
- Yeah. Right.
- Mine didn't stem for many kind of, like,
extra curricular activity,
myself stemmed from porn
as I mentioned before,
and when I started
watching trans, you know,
trans porn and it's
weird to say, but, like,
I got really nervous. I
got really, really nervous
'cause I thought maybe I'd be gay.
And so, you know, I did my research on it,
and I was kind of obsessed with
trying to figure out, like,
what this could mean.
And all the stuff I would
look up with saying like,
"If you watch trans porn,
you're still straight
because they're they're
women", and stuff like that.
But I'm thinking like,
what would my family think?
I've never sought out, and, like,
every time I talk to one in
real, a trans woman in real life
there's no, like, actual attraction there.
So I'm still lost in the fact
of what I actually am attracted to.
But I guess I am still
straight 'cause they are women.
- Quite frankly, right now I
feel happy with my sexuality,
and I feel that it's not wrong
to question your sexuality
in terms of all in America.
Like, you're free to
question whatever you want.
You can question
your religion.
- Yeah.
- You can question your culture.
It's just society.
It's the things that
constrains those certain things
to be what's normal and what's wrong.
- Yeah. I feel like there's
such a strong stigma
to be straight, you know, like, or strong,
like, a more, like, a pushing you into it.
That even right now, I
feel the desire to, like,
explain myself even though
we're anonymous right now.
- Yeah.
- I feel, like,
I've never been with like, I've only been
with, like, actual, like, cis
women, but, like, I don't,
I know this, like, no one is judging me.
We're all here to be honest.
But it is such a stigma that
from the last, you know,
18 years of my life that
in this moment right now
I feel embarrassed and ashamed
for something that should just,
that's just the way it is, you know?
(intense boom)
- [Interviewer] I'm scared of dying.
(countdown beeping)
- I think of it as, like,
I'm extremely scared of that.
I mean, I watched my father
die like right before me.
It's a scary thing. They
just stop breathing.
And just the idea of, like, nothing
is just extremely terrifying to me.
It's like, you don't really
know what's going on.
Like, are you even thinking,
are you even there?
You're just a blip out of just space.
- It is terrifying. You, we don't know.
And as a Christian, I want
to pretend that, like,
I know that there's, you
know, heaven and hell,
but at the end of the day,
I genuinely don't know.
- Yeah. I think I was always had the fear
as a kid growing up that,
you know, I'm gonna die,
and, like, not fulfill, like,
what I wanted to do here on Earth, right?
But every time I thought about dying
it was as an old person.
But two years ago when I
started working as a lifeguard,
this lady and her friend came
to the pool, and, you know,
I have the music going and everything.
She just starts having a seizure.
And luckily, you know,
I did everything right,
and EMS showed up, and she was safe.
But then two weeks later
she, unfortunately,
had another seizure while
driving, and she died.
And that's when I realized life is, like,
it can happen to anyone at any point.
And if I just die and don't
do anything with my life,
then that's what I'm scared of.
- I said that I don't fear death
because I, unlike you guys,
I don't really have an experience,
so much hands-on experience with death.
- Am I afraid of the fact
that I will die someday?
No, but I think, you
know, obviously the fact
that it might come way
sooner than you expect
is a scary thought.
But, like, it's the one
thing that makes life, like,
special, you know what I mean?
It's the one thing I feel like
that actually gives meaning to it.
'Cause if you would never die
then you would never
do anything, you know?
Yeah, 'cause you would always
have more time to do it.
(intense boom) (countdown beeping)
- Do you guys feel like
you can actually be
your genuine self when you're,
like, talking to a girl
or hanging out with a girl?
- There's definitely
difference between, like,
talking or opening up to like
my friends that are girls
versus like a girl that I'm interested in.
- Like, obviously, if you're
trying to impress a girl
you're gonna be dressed nicely.
You're gonna wear some cologne,
and you're not gonna, like,
fight around her, right?
It's like, it's a filter thing.
But, like, when it comes to your mom,
like your mom's a girl, and I
wholeheartedly trust my mom.
So I'm gonna be myself around
the people I trust more.
- I guess that's what it is.
I just, there's a lot of times I walk away
with talking to a girl
I'm really interested in,
and I'm like, "Man, I wasn't just,
I didn't just go up and be me."
And then my best friend, right?
He's or not my, he used
to be my best friend.
He's kind of a womanizer,
but I see him get so much
like, you know, success.
And every time I've gotten
success is doing things
that he's done, which is just putting
on facade, and telling them
what they want to hear.
- I think it's good to be
yourself because, I mean,
you can only put a mask on for so long.
- It's refreshing to talk
to people and realize that
I'm not the only one who feels
a certain way about things.
It is, it's nice, and it's a
step in the right direction
for me in becoming more comfortable
with being open and honest with everybody.
- I think just the
whole open conversation,
like, this won't bite me in the end later
or, like, someone's not gonna
listen to this and think,
"Oh, that guy's bad."
I have more safety of
expressing my honest opinions
and, whether those be good
opinions or bad opinions,
it's like, it's a better way
to express one's true self
without trying to be influenced
by what high school is.
And all the people
influencing you in high school
because, frankly, high school
is just popular culture.
What people think is popular.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so much.
(intense music)